hola a todos mi nombre es alfonso de los
ríos y hoy vengo a hablar de emprender
desde y para latinoamérica
te imaginas un mundo en el que
tuviéramos mucho más tiempo para hacer
lo que nos apasiona desde pasar más
tiempo con nuestros familiares y amigos
desarrollar esa habilidad que tanto
hemos querido para nuestro trabajo o
vida personal o simplemente leer un
libro antes de dormir
pero porque nos faltaría tiempo si
tomamos en cuenta las 8 horas diarias en
las que dormimos nos daríamos cuenta de
que más del 50% del tiempo en el que
estamos despiertos
estamos en camino al trabajo o
trabajando y el problema de esto es que
el error se ha vuelto parte de nuestro
día a día como a través de actividades
operativas más que estratégicas donde
nos dedicamos a hacer reportes manuales
a comunicarnos con proveedores o
simplemente a perder información que se
va a través de correos electrónicos
quizás lo hacemos así porque lo venimos
haciendo así por los últimos 20 años o
porque no vamos a cambiar nuestra manera
de hacerlo de un día para el otro pero
la realidad es que estoy convencido de
que con un proceso simple de
digitalización podríamos eliminar la
fricción en nuestro día a día en las
jornadas laborales y así mejorar nuestra
calidad de vida mucho más allá del
trabajo
es por eso que quiero compartir un poco
de mis aprendizajes y experiencias a
través del tiempo
cuando tenía 11 años aprendí a programar
viendo vídeos en youtube y escuelas en
línea de manera autodidacta donde
prácticamente replicaba código y
aplicaciones que alguien estaba haciendo
en el vídeo y yo los adaptaba a mis
necesidades quizás eran muy básicos pero
a través del tiempo agarraba en
complejidad y me di dando cuenta del
poder que teníamos en esta generación
que era que básicamente podíamos llegar
al otro lado del mundo con un invento
que no había tenido una inversión
significativa sino solamente podíamos
estar en nuestra habitación con la
computadora familiar y desarrollar algo
que le dé valor a otra persona
conforme pasaron los años le vi tomando
más seriedad a este tema y de ser una
actividad diaria y un hobby que yo tenía
lo convertí en una pasión cada vez mis
proyectos tenían más valor y los veía de
una forma de negocio o mínimo así
trataba de hacerlo empecé a publicar mis
proyectos en plataformas como facebook
mini clip y así generar mi primer fuente
de ingresos
entre estos proyectos puede desarrollar
un software para administrar
restaurantes una aplicación para lavar
tu auto e incluso un software en el que
detectamos el acoso escolar en más de 6
universidades en el país
de pronto llegó el momento de pasar a
universidad decide estudiar ingeniería
en tecnologías computacionales que era
una carrera que yo quería conocer ya que
por los últimos años había estado
programando y creando proyectos pero la
realidad es que me topé con un modelo
educativo distinto a lo que yo estaba
acostumbrado donde nos enseñaban la
teoría la mejor forma de hacerlo y cómo
podíamos optimizar todos estos procesos
y yo lo venía haciendo de una manera
distinta donde me equivocaba en el
proceso y probablemente la calidad era
distinta pero terminaba aprendiendo
mucho más que de una manera educativa
tradicional eso me causó demasiada
preocupación y angustia tanto en mi vida
educativa como en mi vida personal
porque pues por el simple hecho de que
las calificaciones no estaban rindiendo
como yo quería y nada más no me adaptaba
con mis compañeros de clase y que
parecía que entendían mucho los métodos
en los que programaban
en ese momento decidí aplicar a más de
40 empresas en california
sin una idea de saber que se necesitaba
para la visa o si podía ser aplicable
con el 17 años a estas empresas una de
ellas me dio la oportunidad de
entrevistarme en persona en california
tomé un vuelo y me aceptaron como
practicante resultó ser parte de la
familia del buscador más grande que hay
en el mundo
y al final de cuentas era un exacto el
valor de este extracto era que un día
estabas en el departamento de finanzas
al siguiente estaba desarrollando una
aplicación una plataforma y al siguiente
día estaba atendiendo a un cliente para
ver si podíamos levantar los números de
ese mes pero la realidad es que el
aprendizaje que estaba atendiendo en el
día a día no se podría comparar con algo
parecido estaba al lado de las mentes
más brillantes de inteligencia
artificial de búsquedas en plataformas y
de cualquier proceso digital que hubiera
conocido antes
de ser practicante me convertí en un
ingeniero senior o fusta donde ya no
nada más estaba desarrollando sino a mis
18 años tenía un equipo el al que
lideraba y estábamos dirigiendo uno de
los proyectos más importantes de la
empresa
en ese momento y cuando pensaba que
estaba creando mi vida en california
conocí a max y quién
poco a poco nos conocimos y vimos que
trabajando éramos muy fuertes las
debilidades que yo veía eran fortalezas
en maxi y viceversa
cenando una vez conecte los recuerdos de
mi infancia con todo lo que había
aprendido estos últimos años mis papás
se dedicaban tenían una empresa de
logística tradicional donde lo que
hacían era mover mercancías de punto a
punto ve desde cualquier lugar en el
mundo podían ser tráilers contenedores
marítimos o carga aéreo
este proceso llevaba demasiada
información porque había muchas partes
involucradas desde proveedores agentes
aduanales el cliente que quería mover la
mercancía y navieras involucradas en el
proceso nos dimos cuenta de la inmensa
área de oportunidad que había y así en
noviembre de 2018 nacional ports que es
la primera
plataforma digital para agentes de carga
en latinoamérica es decir a lo que nos
dedicamos es a que los clientes que
quieren mover mercancía tienen acceso a
una plataforma donde pueden ver todo lo
relacionado este embarque mucho más allá
de la geolocalización de este contenedor
sino facturas que están conectadas
directamente al gobierno líneas de
producción departamento de compras e
incluso una plataforma para los agentes
aduanales y proveedores en el otro lado
del mundo
esto nos ayudaba a darle la vuelta a un
proceso que era el mismo que hace más de
50 años porque porque normalmente para
mover un contenedor se necesitan más de
300 correos electrónicos entre el
cliente y el agente de carga que en este
caso somos nosotros esto sin involucrar
a todos los los símbolos todas las
personas que actúan en la cadena de
suministro
así como nosotros tuvimos la oportunidad
de encontrar una necesidad en la
industria y de poder digitalizar estos
procesos
nuestra misión decir mucho más allá de
hacer una plataforma para las empresas
sino de poder empoderar a todos los
equipos de logística en latinoamérica
que puedan reducir sus horas de reportes
de gráficas a tener acceso a la
información automática y simplemente
desplegarlo en una plataforma
es por eso que estoy convencido que
todos podemos ser agentes de cambio en
la industria en la que estamos mucho más
allá de saber programar o no el chiste
está en encontrar una necesidad latente
en nuestro día a día de jornadas
laborales
basta basta con reflexionar el como en
nuestro día a día desde hoy en día cómo
nos movemos de punto a punto con
plataformas en línea como compramos
boletos de avión o reservamos un hotel o
como hacemos nuestros pedidos de comida
a domicilio
hace menos de 10 años el proceso era
completamente distinto para movernos de
punto a punto que teníamos que tomar un
taxi donde no íbamos a saber qué ruta
iba a tomar o qué costo final tendría
y cuando queríamos signos de viaje
teníamos que ir a una agencia de viajes
donde nos iban a dar las opciones de
vuelo o de hotel
y para pedir a domicilio marca vamos al
restaurante y grabamos nuestra dirección
esta dirección muchas veces falla vamos
porque no sabíamos la entre calle y
terminábamos sin recibir el producto
yo creo que el mundo no está cambiando
mi teoría es que el mundo cambio hace un
tiempo cuando decidimos cambiar nuestros
modelos a enfocarnos en la productividad
y no en ser operativos
así que si el mundo no está cambiando el
mundo ya ha cambiado gracias